أكد حزب النصر في
الدائرة 13 في ميشيغان أنه من
المحتمل أن تكون
أول امرأة مسلمة وأول
فلسطينية في الكونجرس عندما فازت في
الانتخابات التمهيدية في أغسطس ، ولم يرشحها أي جمهوري
في الانتخابات العامة.
انتصار تاريخي في واشنطن
العاصمة وفي الضفة الغربية في
قرية بيت أو تولوكا ،
يتم استقبال كل زائر لمنزل عائلة تالي
بالقهوة والحلويات
وجبة خفيفة احتفالية تقليدية يظهرها لنا ابن عمها
حول منزل العائلة ولدت تولي في
ديترويت لكنها  زارت عائلتها مرارًا وتكرارًا
على مر السنين وتقول عائلتها إنها عادت أيضًا
إلى هنا لحضور حفل زفافها ، وتفخر بولاف
بجذورها الفلسطينية في المقابلات التي أجرتها
في
الخمسينيات والستينيات من القرن الماضي ، والصراع بين
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين ،
اتُهمت بالتقلّب بشأن قضية رئيسية
من التعبير عن دعمها
لحل الدولتين ، وفلسطين المستقلة التي
تجلس إلى جانب إسرائيل ، ودعم
دولة واحدة متكاملة تتكون من العرب.
واليهود الذين تسببوا في دعمها
لمجموعة J Street اليهودية الليبرالية ،
جعلوها على خلاف مع
السلطات السياسية هنا في الضفة الغربية في
أفراد عائلتها في قرية أسلافها فقط
يأملون أن تتمكن من المساعدة في تسليط الضوء على
القضية الفلسطينية في متجر النظافة
الفلسطينية في فلسطين.  كانت نيفادا ياني هي
الحليف المؤهل للنخبة الأمريكية المؤهلة لواكاماو لينيل كونيا
إلى يسار المؤسسة الديمقراطية التي
سجلت تأييدًا من
العدالة التقدمية للديمقراطيين ، وانتصاراتها جزءًا
من موجة جديدة من السياسة وموجة جديدة
من النساء المتنوعات المتجهات إلى واشنطن
العاصمة أو في  ليبرمان سي ان ان القدس
لكم